it must feel incredible after all this
time
to finally be able to talk about
canada's drag race how does it feel now
to be able to finally talk about it
amazing so good i mean i've kind of gone
through this before when i was competing
on the show
i'm just as excited to be a judge on the
show as i was to be a contestant so it's
been
it's been hard to keep quiet but i'm
just so excited that we got to share
this with everybody now
now that trailers have been released
into the world it's just been
such a dream to see the response from
from the world at large
after many years of dreaming it's
official
we're looking for canada's first drag
superstar
oh canada start your engines
the queens are some of the best in
canada promos all look
incredible can you speak to what we'll
be seeing
there's so many different kinds of drag
in general and so many different kinds
of dragon canada that we have on the
show
and it's going to be really exciting for
everyone to kind of see and discover
everyone's own unique personality and
their own unique drag because it all
is very quirky and different canada's
about to bring it i don't think y'all
are ready
holby crown the queen of the north
jeffrey you've sat on the judging panel
of
drag race a few times now um how did
uh these queens here in canada compare
did they exceed your expectations
they blew my mind truly the only
reference for canadian drag queens that
i had
was the one and only brooklyn heights so
she set a very
very high bar and my expectations really
were
up here and all of these queens if not
matched
surpassed my expectations people are
going to be blown
away honey you knocked it out of the
park
stacey was it just the most fun set to
be on what was it like
oh my gosh it was so much fun it was a
great time it was the most fun i've had
on a job
i have to say like the most fun a lot of
laughter
there was even tears too queen to queen
i know the pressure of this competition
but i can promise you it's gonna be
worth it this is your time to shine
this experience will change your life
completely
so as the judges of season one what are
you looking for
in a season one winner the three of you
being judged i'm sure you all have your
own
versions of that list i'm looking for
somebody with confidence
and professionalism and somebody that's
going to be able to go out there like a
queen that's going to go out there and
like really represent
yeah i mean i'm looking for the obvious
charisma uniqueness-driven talent
like stacy said really a go-getter we
want someone who's a hustler we want
someone who's going to take this and run
with it and really
turn this into a life-changing
opportunity for them and i'm looking for
somebody who
has heart and who is willing to show
their heart and share it with the world
there's something to be said for sweet
sensitive souls and somebody who's
willing to
tap into their own authenticity and
vulnerability and
that's how the audience falls in love
with you and that's how we as judges
fall in love with you